qui a terrible dans cette photo c'est
que là je vois vraiment le grand no et
celui qui est en forme celui qui respire
la vie celui qui a plein de projets et m
rappelle avec beaucoup de dureté que
quelques années après cette photo noël a
été diagnostiquée de cette saleté est
parti trois ans après à l'âge de 10 ans
nos horaires aujourd'hui 17 ans et je
suis sûr qu'il n'aurait rien perdu de
son énergie et probablement de sa beauté
aussi voilà cette photo elle est aussi
agréable à voir qu'elle est qu'elle est
difficile à accepter
[Musique]
en fin d'année 2011 je me rends à necker
avec n'aurait puisque depuis quelques
semaines il a du mal à bouger une deux
une de ses mains et le lendemain matin
alors que magalie
me rejoins nous sommes reçus par la chef
de service de neurochirurgie necker qui
nous annonce en même temps que notre
fils a un cancer que cette tumeur et
cancéreuses et qu'il va mourir de façon
certaine et rapide
après l'émotion après ce coup de
tonnerre après tout ça on reprend nos
esprits avec magali et on part du
principe on déclare que nous note gosses
on allait le sauver et qu'on allait
faire tout ce qui était dans nos moyens
pour le sauver
[Musique]
je
pendant les vacances puisqu'on a passé
le mois d'août à la maison no est alité
il perd l'ouïe on communique avec lui
sous forme de gestes et fin septembre
il meurt une première fois à la maison
je leur à nîmes et quatre jours après il
meurt à l'hôpital
il faut qu'on arrive à bout de cette
maladie quand je revois cette vidéo
aujourd'hui évidemment toujours
l'horreur d'avoir perdu nos équipes
l'anme une certaine satisfaction d'avoir
mobilisé un comité de campagne mobiliser
des gens
[Musique]
on a levé 14 millions d'euros en deux
ans et demi et donc nous avons déjà
financer du matériel des chercheurs des
encadrants des chefs de projets
ils nous poussent encore constamment et
je crois pour nous c'est un mélange de
d'admiration de fierté d'être avec lui
dans ce projet j'ai vraiment cru un
moment que noël et réussir à passer
entre les balles son état de santé le
justifiait justifier mes espoirs et
l'énergie que je mettais pour continuer
à trouver des traitements pour le sauver
moi je suis fermement décidé à venir à
bout du cancer des enfants tant que je
serai là et en fait pour m'accompagner
avec gustave roussy
j'ai besoin de quelques dizaines ou
quelques centaines de personnes
aussi convaincu que nous parce que on ne
peut pas vivre
on ne peut pas laisser vivre d'autres
familles ce moment où on a la double
nouvelle votre enfant un cancer il va
mourir c'est sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]